when you're a kid there's only one day a  year more special than any other day and  we are the magic behind that day  so let's get these [ __ ] kids some  [ __ ] presents  hey merry christmas whoa  you're on my naughty list more american  kids believe in you than they do in  vaccines or the holocaust that's great i  mean disheartening for america but great  for us but the position of santa has  mostly been a white man's game  exactly it's [ __ ] crazy things have  got to change i want to be the next  santa if this is your dream you have to  at least make your case  you got to get intimate with that jolly  that was without exaggeration one of the  worst previews i've ever seen in my life  for anything ever and i didn't even play  the worst parts because there's another  45 seconds or so where we learn more  about how santa is bad because he's  white and male and what we really need  is a non-white non-male santa comedy has  died in our country